let's say you wanted to buy a popular
Rolex Daytona watch a new one would cost
you 14 800 but if you wanted to buy a
used version of this same watch you
might need to pay over thirty eight
thousand dollars
so why are people spending more money to
get a used Rolex if you use your watch
probably for 10 times then we're not of
the same mindset here's why the used
watch Market is booming and what Rolex
is doing to get in on the action this is
the economics of used Rolexes
experts suggest that it takes about a
year to make a Rolex and wait list for
new watches can last months to years and
because of that these days you can't
walk into any Rolex store any Rolex
dealer and just get any watch that you
want for the past few years as demand
has increased Rolex has not been able to
keep up with that demand their
production just can't match the number
of people that want a Rolex if you've
got 10 20 000 to burn you really want to
watch you're probably going to go to the
resale Market because the watch that you
want is going to be available there and
so the prices on the resale Market have
then gone up because there's more people
going to that market 29 of collectors
reported paying more than retail price
for their most recent pre-owned watch
according to a report from Boston
Consulting Group and 40 percent said
that one of their top reasons was that
they were able to avoid long waiting
lists in the first-hand market this has
created a boom in the secondary Market
pre-owned watch sales reach 22 billion
in 2021. the used sector is actually
growing faster than the primary market
and for some people used watches are
worth more than new ones that's because
some rare styles are more desirable or
because Rolex has discontinued certain
models and colors in an older model
Rolex can have a patina it can have some
wear marks and so those kind of personal
details those kind of personal age marks
those are things that collectors might
want there is also a bragging Rich thing
where if you have a Rolex from the 70s
or the 80s you're able to say it's from
this era it's you know 20 30 years older
than I am and that is just kind of cool
to collectors in a way the market about
a decade ago was softer than it is right
now back then you could sell a watch and
get a return on it but you could also
sell a Rolex and it could have
depreciated in value and you could lose
money on it these days you now will
likely make more money off of it if you
sell it on the resale Market much of the
success of the used watch Market is due
to the rise of online watch resale
marketplaces over the past decade that's
where people like Paul and Carol come in
get over there buddy the husband and
wife Duo run Bob's watches an online
Marketplace for buying selling and
trading luxury watches they say that
they currently have one of the largest
selections of used Rolex watches in the
world I started out in the watch
business because I could see that there
was no real safe transparent honest
place for people to buy and sell
pre-owned watches it's been an upward
Trend since 2010 we've been growing
consistently about 30 to 40 percent year
over year two years ago we did a hundred
million dollars in sales there's so much
more for us to tap into that we haven't
had the bandwidth to get to because the
growth has been so fast and furious and
Paul and Carol love Rolexes sales of
used watches online already exceed
auction and store sales and one report
predicts they're going to reach close to
60 percent of the second hand luxury
Market by 2026. during the pandemic the
stock market goes crazy you have the
kind of crypto phenomenon you have meme
stocks happening and people have a lot
of extra capital and they're taking that
in many cases and they're putting it
toward assets luxury goods and in a lot
of cases watches starting in 2020 used
luxury watches sold for 1.5 to 3 times
their retail prices Rolex is a brand
that's really recognizable as design
it's you know easy to spot on the street
and a lot of people they'll see that
their friend has a given Rolex and they
think I want that too but Rolex the
company only sold new watches which
meant that the brand wasn't involved
with used watch sales that is until late
2022 Rolex opened a certified pre-owned
program for its used watches retailers
can send used Rolexes that are at least
three years old back to the watchmaker
the certified pre-owned program verifies
that a watch is an authentic Rolex and
works properly then retailers can sell
the watch with an official Rolex
certificate the program is already
active in one retail chain in six
different countries another chain of
official Rolex retailers in the U.S will
enter the program this may buying a
watch with Rolex certification could be
a draw for first-time buyers you're
buying a watch on the internet it can be
a little bit of a daunting experience of
all the watches on our website today
almost 50 percent of them already have
the original box and papers from Rolex
we've offered a CPO program a certified
pre-owned program now for almost five
years the only thing really new about it
is that Rolex is certifying and doing
the paperwork behind it so I don't feel
that there's any increased competition
but I do feel that the market is big
enough for everybody to participate
today people buy Rolexes online the way
that they might buy toilet paper so it's
really not a premium or a specialized
experience there's still that consumer
that wants to have that experience of
going into a store and being waited on
of kind of being shown watches from a
glass display case and making it feel
more special because they're buying
something of such a high value this
certified pre-owned program means that
Rolex can take a cut out of a market
that it previously left untapped but
things might contain continue to shift
for the luxury watch Market the used
watch Market is cooling down as sellers
eager to make a profit have flooded the
market with inventory recent data shows
the number of Rolex watches available to
buy second hand roughly doubled from the
beginning of 2022 to September of the
same year on those really coveted kind
of brand name watches so to speak the
ones that collectors talk about the
resale value has gone down a little bit
resellers people that watch that market
they do say that the prices have come
back down to earth a little bit but the
volume of sales the amount of sales
happening that Still Remains pretty high
we're seeing still a large number of
transactions in the resale Market your
day and day on Rolex is still retaining
a lot of value on the resale Market you
can still get a pretty good return for
it as with any resale Market there is a
risk that the Rolex Market can fall out
at any time five years ago we might not
have been talking about craziness Market
is and five years from now we might not
be talking about how crazy this Market
is the market is so large that to a
certain extent both things can be true
you know people that watch this Market
will say that that's just actually a
reflection of how big the Market is now
where it can behave in many different
ways just because it is this kind of
really large transactional Marketplace
[Music]
foreign